qu'on retrouve tout de suite karina
chahbour notre envoyé spécial karina
bonjour comment ce défilé a été perçu
par les russes
mais vous tester un petit peu si je puis
me permettre comme le 14 juillet en
france les gens sont surtout venus ici
en famille pour profiter du défilé pour
faire plaisir aux enfants pour voir les
blindés et en cela il était plutôt bien
très content le discours disons de
vladimir poutine n'était pas au centre
de leurs intérêts et peut-être que la
pointe de déception elle s'était c'est
parce que c'est tout simplement parce
qu'il n'y a pas eu de défilé aérien en
raison des mauvaises conditions météo
alors certains disaient que et se
consoler parce qu'il n'avait pu assister
aux répétitions
d'autres qui sont restés chez eux devant
leur télévision et bien rompue les
absents
et c'est un des paradoxes et c'est donc
sans doute mais la déception elle est
beaucoup plus grande j'aime la dîmière
poutine dans la mesure où ce mec il est
aérien devait être le clou du spectacle
vous rappelle que huit avions de chasse
étaient censés former un z en soutien
aux troupes russes actuellement en
ukraine et qu'il y avait aussi on
parlait beaucoup de cet avenant dit de
l'apocalypse qui est un avion de
commandement qui est adapté aux conflits
un nucléaire et qui devait lui aussi
traversé le ciel comme une autre